[Music]  intelligence  stamina  courage in the heart  my business is dogs  he's under sized is trouble  [Music]  well good afternoon is untrainable  what does he bring to the breed the  heart of a survivor  he outran every single one of them he's  not a sled dog he's a lead dog  what we have in our children is an  epidemic the death sentence  they found it sure round trip is 600  miles  you see that storm in the horizon only  one man and one dog can make that run  he's 12 years old he's too old he'll  never make that distance that one  morning pumpkin  [Music]  my guess is we don't find him till the  fall  all right Togo and for us to find out  who we are  I always thought he lived for the sled  when all along  but he lived for  was me  hey Tomo  [Music]